- [Narrator] Salary ranges have come
to New York City job postings.
This month a new Salary
transparency law took
effect that requires most
employers to provide good faith
salary ranges on job posts.
- The significance of all of this is huge.
Pay information has
been secret for decades
- [Narrator] But since the
legislation went into effect
job seekers are finding
that some companies are
sidestepping the new regulation
by listing salary ranges so wide
that they stretch hundreds
of thousands of dollars.
So does this loophole
mean New York City's new
law is ineffective?
Pay transparency laws exist
to different degrees in
some states in the US,
but Colorado and now
New York City stand out
in that they require this
information in job postings.
Experts say New York City's
Salary Disclosure Law
may be especially impactful
because of the size
of the city's economy and the
number of companies there.
New York City is now the
biggest job market in the US
to require employers to
list pay ranges and job ads.
- This law has national
implications because
if a job could conceivably
be done in New York
employers would have to comply with it.
And that applies to remote roles as well.
And already we're
starting to see companies
across the US begin to
list pay for remote roles
wanting to comply with
the New York legislation
- [Narrator] Officials say
the New York City law helps
eliminate inherent bias in
setting employee salaries.
Last year, the Pew Research Center found
that women earned around 84%
of what men earned in 2020.
That gap has narrowed significantly
from 40 years ago when women earned
around 64% of what men did.
- Lawmakers and other supporters hope laws
like this will lead to
more equitable workplaces
will lead to more fairness in the process
and will help to sort of
level the playing field really
from the moment someone gets hired.
- [Narrator] New York's
law did face pushback
from prominent business groups
like the partnership for New York City
which said the legislation
was overly burdensome
for employers who needed
more time to comply
with the new rules.
- Ultimately, the city did
give companies more time
and the city pushed
back the implementation
of a law from May until
November of this year.
Right now, the partnership
for New York City said most employers
are on board with this.
They may not be thrilled about it
but they're largely complying.
- [Narrator] Since the
transparency law went into effect
companies have pursued a variety
of approaches to disclosure.
- Some companies still
aren't complying at all.
Others are posting really broad ranges.
Some companies have had ranges
that vary only by $5,000
and so it's a really mixed picture so far.
- [Narrator] The roles that
have attracted the most
attention are those
with wide Salary ranges.
A trauma surgeon
in the Mount Sinai health
system could earn anywhere
from $384,000 to $800,000 or more.
A tax executive
at Price Waterhouse
Coopers could make $158,000
or nearly triple that.
A radiologist position
at another Mount Sinai
Hospital listed a job
that could pay as much
as $525,000 or roughly half
that amount at $260,000.
- One of the really fuzzy parts
of this law is what
constitutes a good faith range
because employers have made
the case that sometimes
ranges need to be super broad
because they don't know who
they wanna recruit for a role.
Job seekers have said
that more specific
ranges are more helpful.
- [Narrator] The agency tasked
with enforcing the law is
New York City's Commission
on Human Rights, which will rely mostly
on citizen complaints
to investigate companies
that post jobs without
the pay range listed.
It's unclear whether the city's Commission
on Human Rights will
consider the broad Salary
ranges a good faith
attempt to post salaries.
- One co-sponsor of the
latest legislation told me
that there may need to
be additional legislation
soonish to address the fact
that there are overly broad ranges.
This council member said
that he would like to see
a mechanism, for example
that prevents ranges that
are double the minimum
and maximum.
So example, a range
from 60,000 to 120,000.
He would see as unacceptable.